la fin de la scène dans la cuisine où on
voit le velociraptor retrousser les
lèvres visiblement pas content de voir
son repas lui filer entre les doigts
alors évidemment un velociraptor
n'aurait pas pu retrousser les lèvres de
cette façon puisque sur leur crâne ils
n'ont absolument aucune attache
musculaire pour les lèvres contrairement
aux mammifères les velociraptor font
partie de la famille des sauropodes si
de la famille des reptiles ainsi que les
oiseaux d'ailleurs et non pas les
attaches musculaire qu'il faut pour
pouvoir retrousser les lèvres néanmoins
cette scène elle est très intéressante
parce que elle pose la question faut-il
représenter les théropodes avec des
lèvres ou sans lèvres
c'est un débat qui est extrêmement
vigoureux dans les communautés paléo
artistique faut-il représenter les
théropodes avec des lèvres ou non et le
film jurassic park est très intéressant
de ce point de vue puisque déjà en 1993
il répondait à la fois oui et non alors
pourquoi il répond à la fois oui et non
et bien tout simplement parce que les
velociraptor ont des lèvres alors que le
tyrannosaure n'en a pas le tyrannosaure
vous voyez c'est d'en dépasser donc il
n'a pas de lèvres alors déjà de quel
genre de lèvres on parle on parle de
lèvres reptilienne c'est à dire que si
vous regardez un lézard comme un varan
de komodo par exemple ce que vous verrez
ce sont des lèvres non musculaire donc
en fait c'est juste un rideau des cayes
qui recouvre les dents quand la bouche
et fermez donc les varans de komodo
quand ils ont la bouche fermée vous ne
voyez pas du tout les dents dépassé
d'ailleurs même quand il ouvre la bouche
vous ne voyez pas les dents dépassé
parce que ses dents sont toujours
recouverts par ce rideau des cas et donc
quand on pose la question faut-il
représenter les dinosaures théropodes
avec des lèvres
ce sont des lèvres reptilienne des
lèvres qui ne sont formés que d'un
rideau des cayes donc jamais il n'est
question de représenter les théropodes
avec des lèvres mammalienne musculaire
comme nous on en a qui sont expressive
qu'on peut bouger au gré de nos
expressions faciales et du coup les
designers des dinosaures de jurassic
park ils ont pris le parti de
représenter les velociraptor avec des
lèvres mais le tyrannosaure sans lèvres
alors ça ça peut se motiver assez
facilement les velociraptor on dit
qu'ils sont intelligents on veut montrer
qu'ils sont intelligents alors qu'est ce
qu'on fait on leur donne des expressions
faciales donc on leur donne d'élèves
un peu comme les primates du coup et le
tyrannosaure lui c'est le monstre dans
ce qu'on veut faire ressortir c'est son
côté monstrueux donc il faut que ses
dents ressortent et pour que ses dents
ressortent
eh bien il faut lui enlever ses lèvres
parce que tyrannosaure si vous leur
présentez avec des lèvres et bat
normalement elle devrait recouvrir
totalement les dents et même quand il a
la bouche ouverte et bien on ne devrait
pas pouvoir voir ses dents donc la
grande question maintenant c'est
laquelle de ces deux représentations est
bonne eh bien là c'est là où la
littérature scientifique n'êtes
absolument d'aucune aide parce que
croyez le ou non mais la littérature
scientifique sur le sujet est
extrêmement pauvre il y a très très peu
de littérature scientifique publiée ou
non sur le sujet est ce que les
théropodes avait des lèvres ou pas et ça
ça contraste énormément avec le débat
parmi les paléo artiste qui a lieu par
exemple sur twitter ou sur instagram
oula ça s'envoie des filles ont à tour
de bras mais la science ne se fait pas
sur twitter alors que dit la science est
bien la science déjà elle souligne le
fait qu'il n'y a absolument pas de
données permettant de répondre
définitivement à la question des lèvres
la première chose qu'il faut savoir
c'est qu'il n'y a aucun registre fossile
de lèvres ou d'absence de lèvres chez
les théropodes la seule chance qu'on
aurait de pouvoir répondre à cette
question ce serait de trouver une momie
d'un animal complet avec les tissus mous
conservez donc une momie qui se seraient
ensuite fossilisés on parle bien d'une
momie fossilisés ensuite et là sur ce
genre de fossiles on serait capable de
voir si oui ou non il y avait des lèvres
qui recouvrait les dents nous n'avons
pas ce genre de fossiles en tout cas pas
pour les théropodes on a de très jolis
mots me fossilisés d'adp rose or et là
on voit très bien le bec
on a un crâne de camarasaurus avec un
tout petit bout de peau fossilisés sur
la mâchoire qui montre que en tout cas
qui suggère que les sauropodes avaient
eux aussi des lèvres par contre pour les
théropodes on a rien donc au sein des
dinosaures vous avez à la fois des
représentants à bec et d'autres qui
avaient des lèvres donc c'est un peu
compliqué et c'est encore plus compliqué
quand ensuite on essaye de regarder les
proches parents modernes des dinosaures
donc on regarde la position des
dinosaures dans la classification animal
on va regarder quelles sont leurs plus
proches parents et qu'est ce qu'on
constate et bien on constate que les
plus proches parents des dinosaures font
partie du grand groupe des arts queloz
or les arts queloz or c'est le groupe
qui comprend les oiseaux
dinosaures les ptérosaures les
crocodiles et les tortues et qu'est ce
qu'on constate dans ce groupe et bien
que personne n'a de lèvres là dedans les
tortues et les oiseaux dont un bec
donc il nous aide pas beaucoup à
répondre à la question les crocos eux
ils n'ont pas de bec
mais par contre ils n'ont absolument pas
de lèvres dont croco et alligators n'ont
pas de lèvres qui recouvrent leur dans
l'eure dans son apparente quand ils ont
la bouche fermée
et puis on a les ptérosaures qui sont
eux aussi éteint mais comme on a par
exemple renfort un cul ce dont on voit
les dents s'entrecroiser sur le crâne et
donc on imagine difficilement comment
les ptérosaures pouvait avoir des lèvres
et en plus il ya beaucoup de ptérosaure
qui devait avoir un mec aussi on imagine
que les ptérosaures d' n'avait pas non
plus de lèvres
donc a priori si on regarde juste les
proches parents modernes des dinosaures
on serait tenté de dire bas que les
dinosaures ne devait pas avoir de lèvres
contrairement à leurs très lointains
cousins les lézards parce que tous les
reptiles qui aujourd'hui porte des
lèvres appartiennent au groupe des
lipides aux oraux morph donc c'est le
groupe des lézards des serpents et du
spen aux dons et donc il est fort
possible que les lèvres n'ait évolué
qu'une seule fois parmi les reptiles pas
chez les arcs et laws of pas chez
l'ancêtre commun des arts queloz or et
des lipides aux oraux morte mais une
seule fois chez les l'epide aux oraux
morph et si c'est le cas et bien on ne
s'attend pas à trouver de lèvres chez
aucun archosaures dinosaures inclus et
dans ce cas comparer les dinosaures au
lézard pour dire qu'ils avaient des
lèvres ce serait fallacieux puisqu'en
réalité les dinosaures ne sont pas du
tout apparentés aux lézards et il est
fort possible que les lézards est hérité
leurs lèvres de l'ancêtre commun les
pizzas romoff et pas à l'ancêtre en
commun des lipides aux oraux morph et
des arts queloz or donc a priori la
classification la position des
dinosaures dans la classification semble
nous dire assez clairement que les
dinosaures ne devait pas avoir de lèvres
mais il y a des gens qui comptera
argumente en disant que la dessiccation
des dents donc le fait que les dents ne
soit pas recouvert d'un film protecteur
qui les maintiendrait dans l'humidité de
la bouche
cette destination des dents risquerait
de provoquer la craquelure des dans la
fragilisation de l'émail et que par
conséquent ce lord ans aurait été
beaucoup trop fragile à cause de la
sécheresse
alors c'est pas un argument complètement
stupide puisqu'on sait que l'émail chez
les reptiles et les dinosaures l'émail
dentaire
est relativement fragile parce qu'elle
est constituée de cristaux relativement
plus simplement organisé que chez les
mammifères donc les mammifères peuvent
se permettre d'avoir les dents exposé à
la sécheresse
elle risque pas trop de craquer alors
que chez les reptiles les dents elles
risquent de craquer assez facilement
parce que l'organisation de l'émail est
plus simple mais c'est justement pour ça
que les reptiles ont des dents qui se
renouvelle continuellement et les
dinosaures inclut les dinosaures avaient
des rangées de dents qui se renouvelait
tout au long de leur vie comme chez les
crocodiles toute leur vie les dinosaures
perdaient leurs dents et de nouvelles
dents repoussait donc la dessiccation de
l'émail n'était pas un problème en soi
de plus on a des exemples d'animaux qui
avait un émail dentaire aussi simple que
chez les dinosaures comme par exemple
les terres apside donc les reptiles
prémat malien et chez ces animaux là on
a des animaux à dents de sabre et les
animaux à dents de sabre avec toute
l'imagination du monde vous aurez du mal
à vous imaginer qu'ils avaient des
lèvres qui allait recouvrir complètement
leurs dents de sabre donc c'est
fortement improbable que des lèvres et
recouvert leurs dents de sabre et
pourtant c'est dans le sabre ne craquait
pas de ce fait l'argument de la
dessiccation des dents ne tient pas non
plus la route pendant très longtemps ce
qui rend fortement probable l'hypothèse
que les dinosaures finalement n'avait
pas du tout de lèvres et ce serait assez
cohérent avec le fait que chez les
dinosaures comme chez leurs proches
parents on a de nombreuses réapparition
d'une structure où les lèvres
disparaissent complètement et qu'on
appelle le bec
il y a énormément de dinosaures à bec
les ornithologues les ovi raptor les
ornithologues aux orres les ceyrat
obtient évidemment et puis on a plein de
proches parents des dinosaures qui aussi
se sont mis à évoluer avec comme par
exemple les ptérosaures layrac aux ors
et évidemment les tortues et les oiseaux
dont oiseaux qui d'ailleurs compte comme
des dinosaures finalement alors en quoi
l'évolution à répétition d'un bec est
intéressante chez les dinosaures et
leurs proches parents et bien tout
simplement parce que pour pour qu'un mec
puisse apparaître
il faut que deux bases y ait pas
beaucoup de chair sur la face puisque le
bec finalement va résulter en la
disparition de toute forme de chair sur
la face donc tous les muscles tout la
peau va disparaître pour former un bec
corné donc la condition de base pour
qu'un bex forme c'est que déjà de base
il doit pas y avoir beaucoup de viande
sur la tête et notamment pas de lèvres
ainsi l'absence de lèvres expliquerait
pourquoi le bec a évolué à répétition
dans ce groupe
alors il existe encore quelques autres
arguments en la faveur de la présence de
lèvres chez les dinosaures l'un d'entre
eux c'est les dimensions de la tête mais
là j'ai du mal à voir le rapport mais
c'est quelque chose qui a été avancé
dans la littérature
il y a le paléontologue grégory paul qui
a avancé l'hypothèse que la disposition
des dents chez les théropodes serait
indicatrice de la présence de lèvres ou
non donc si les dents se croisent comme
chez les crocodiles donc quand les
crocodiles ont la bouche fermée
vous pouvez voir que les dents du dessus
croiser les dents du dessous donc vous
avez une dent du dessus une dent du
dessous une dent du dessus qu'on peut
voir se croiser sur le côté du du
crocodile
ça ce serait un indicateur de l'absence
de lèvres et c'est quelque chose qu'on
retrouve quasiment pas chez les
dinosaures c'est quelque chose qu'on
retrouve que chez les spinosaures idée
par exemple mais par contre la plupart
des théropodes eux ils ont toutes les
dents du dessus qui recouvre
complètement les dents du dessous un peu
comme ce qu'on voit chez les lipides aux
oraux mort c'est à dire chez les lézards
les serpents et les faits nos dons et ça
pour grégory paul ce serait un
indicateur que la plupart des théropodes
avait des lèvres à part peut-être les
spinosaures idée le problème majeur de
cet argument c'est qu'il néglige
totalement l'existence des alligators
qui ont les dents du dessus qui recouvre
complètement les dents du dessous et qui
pourtant eux non plus n'ont pas de
lèvres exactement comme les crocodiles
et enfin il ya le dernier argument qui
est l'argument de l'anatomie comparée il
y a des gens qui propose de regarder la
façon dont les foramen sont disposés sur
la face alors les faux ramène ce sont
des petits trous et ses petits trous ils
sont là pour conduire des nerfs pour
conduire des vaisseaux sanguins jusque
sur le museau jusque sur la face est
évidemment on s'imagine que plus vous
avez de vaisseaux sanguins et de nerfs
qui arrive sur votre visage et plus vous
allez avoir de chair à innerver et à
alimenter avec du sang
donc il a été proposé évidemment que
plus vous avez des petits foramen sur
votre phase plus vous avez de ces petits
trous pour les nerfs et les vaisseaux
sanguins plus vous êtes susceptibles
d'avoir de viande sur votre visage donc
des muscles donc de la peau et donc
aussi des lèvres sauf qu'apparemment
chez les reptiles ça marche pas du tout
comme ça apparemment chez les reptiles
c'est plus vous avez de trous sur le
visage moins vous avez de lèvres
regardez les tortues
or tu ont plein de trous sur leur museau
qui alimente le bec parce que le bec
c'est une structure vivante c'est la
kératine et 7 karatina la besoin de
beaucoup d'énergie donc beaucoup de
vaisseaux sanguins pour être irriguées
afin de continuer à grandir tout au long
de la vie de la tortue puisque c'est une
structure qui grandit continuellement le
bec
c'est pareil pour les oiseaux si vous
regardez leur bec osseux leurs prêts
maxillaire il est aussi recouvert de
plein de petits trous de plein de petits
trous qui alimente aussi le bec qui
grandit aussi en continu chez les
oiseaux et chez les crocodiles quand
vous regardez le crâne vous avez aussi
des centaines voire même des milliers de
petits trous plein le crâne des
crocodiles et les crocodiles
même s'ils n'ont pas de bec en tout cas
ils n'ont pas de lèvres alors qu'à côté
de ça quand vous regardez les lézards la
plupart des lézards qui ont des lèvres
non pas tant de petits trous que ça est
généralement les trouve bien alignées
juste au dessus de la rangée dentaire
donc ce ne serait pas le nombre élevé de
foramen qui serait indicateur de la
présence de lèvres mais l'opposé en fait
c'est que plus on a de petits foramen et
moins on a de chance d'avoir deux lèvres
parce que les tortues les oiseaux et les
crocodiles ont un très grand nombre de
faux ramène et non pas de lèvres et
al'inverse les lézards eux ont un petit
nombre de faux ramène qui sont bien
organisés et justement quand on regarde
les fossiles qu'est ce qu'on constate et
bien on constate que velociraptor
possède une rangée de faux ramène bien
alignées au dessus de la rangée dentaire
donc quelque chose qui suggérerait la
présence de lèvres alors que chez
tyrannosaure au contraire on a plein de
faux ramène qui recouvre complètement le
museau exactement comme chez les
crocodiles donc quelque chose qui
semblerait être plutôt indicateur d'une
absence de lèvres pour conclure on a
donc le velociraptor qui était plus à
même de posséder des lèvres alors que le
tyrannosaure lui n'en possédaient
probablement pas ce qui est exactement
ce que jurassic park avait proposé en
1993 il y a déjà presque 30 ans ça veut
dire que je racing park avait déjà
prédit l'issue de ce débat presque
trente ans avant qu'il n'apparaisse sur
la toile